друзі всім привіт ну що у нас
цікаві новини
благодатний вогонь зійшов не тільки в
єрусалимі в храмі труни Господньої
друзі а й у брянській області та
підпалив просто по ходу два склади
нафтових ще один арсенал
ракетно-артилерійського управління
Міноборони Росії зараз розповім про
цьому докладніше ви підписуйтесь на
канал, щоб нічого не пропустити за
найважливіше найважливіше та
будучи тут ви знаєте все важливе
військовому політичному дипломатичному
економічному світі і звичайно
інформаційному та й поширюєте
ділитесь цим відео лайк шер комент
передплата все необхідно для того, щоб
якнайбільше людей дізналося правду і
так цієї ночі горять склади
нафтобази в
брянської області більш ніж сто
кілометрів від кордону з Україною на
секундочку
горять настільки сильні та яскраво що туди
привернули з калузького воронезького ну
зрозуміло брянською курскою області
пожежників і навіть із самої Москви що
сталося ніхто не знає літаків
українських не було гелікоптерів теж вони
намагаються розповісти якихось українських
дронах які десь нібито атакують а
ми друзі з вами знаємо просто
благодатний вогонь зійшов зійшов нарешті
на них
благодатний вогонь і я зійшов ви пам'ятаєте у
білгородської області на склад з
боєприпасами на нафтосховища тепер
ось у
зійшов там у брянській області
але він усе йшов на криті ракетний крейсер
Москва те, що тут нахилився на лівий
бік і потонув сайті вже є відео як він
лежить так на боці красиво глибина до речі
близько 40 метрів так що буде класний
дайверський об'єкт після війни буде
класний дайверський туризм з усього світу
їхатимуть а ось тепер він зійшов на
брянську область
подивіться як це красиво було
дійсно краса але дійсно
краса навіщо путін відправляв своє
оточення від цих божевільних якунин їх
покидьків за благодатним вогнем виру солимо
як у нього там виносять із хрестами на
грудей подивіться
[музика]
навіщо було так далеко ось він тут у
брянській області все добре ми чекаємо
коли він уже зійде друзі на кремль
саме час йому звичайно туди сайті ну а
російський пропагандисти звичайно від
всього цього збожеволіли і говорять боже
боже треба мстити треба вдаряти по
центрам
прийняття рішень у Києві, а інші вже
виходить погляд ні ні не в Києві
солов'їв life з'явився якийсь там
новий невідомий пропагандист
яким означає розповідає про те, що
Центрі прийняття рішення ти не в Києві
де друзі послухайте я вважаю що ми
як і попереджали повинні будемо нанести
свій удар у центром прийняття рішень та
не кудись а такими центрами з одного
сторони є київ але якось
Михайло Стрічці у нас в ефірі говорив що
взагалі то
Центру прийняття рішень це не зовсім
київ
хоча туди ось бачите не блінкін шо
сильним приїжджають таємниця ну ось розумієте
у вашингтоні, а все ж ви не б'єте по
вашингтону не виросла ще така
штучка щоб убити по вашингтону не
вистачає сил не вистачає нічого загалом
друзі очевидно
все на рашку паніка нарешті вони
відчули що таке війна і на своїй
території і виявляється це страшне
виявляється горить і виявляється
неприємно та й риють окопи та багато чого
роблять для того, що ну ось страшно
стало стало страшно і не дарма
потихеньку навіть там відкриваються очі у
них хоча сьогодні голова їхній уряд
Мішустін заявив про те що означає і
росія забезпеч а я зараз цитую
Росія забезпечує себе овочами на 87
відсотків і потенціал для зростання є ну
що він мав на увазі що вони перетворили
своїх громадян 87 відсотків овочі
я не хочуть ще й потенціал для зростання не
для них погана новина мені здається навіть
там у них і навіть якщо на всіх цих
пропагандистів починається якраз
зворотний процес і ось у криму мужику за
підлозі свастику
з-значить
машину побили і про що він повною мірою
відчув що таке носити свастику
подивіться
кислоту фарби зв'язку
облити до-поп
також облітати бруса до
сліз та багажники
на всіх
не знаю зателефонував до поліції
зараз з'ясовуватимемо лобове розбив
найпряміший змальовані
навмисне дужки ось такі друзі справа
ось у нас
ви побачили все коли ж у криму у людей
вже розплющились очі чи ще буде
некрасивий же гиря вам правда
друзі тримаємо лад